so what is the story with this Gunther
you just threw him across the room as if
he was just a toy and not a penguin with
emotions and feelings don't worry about
Gunther he'll be okay
why do you call him come to find out my
friend Gunther this is wizard okay so
I'm trying to gather what I just watch
this one this one is especially odd oh
okay so this skeleton guy in a robe is
like you know do you want some free
magic power sort of like a drug dealer
really yeah he opens up this magic door
which is a great design by the way I
just sound like it has an awesome design
and they go through and it's like this
really backwards Harry Potter's taught a
style school and he gets all these magic
powers but it turns out the last one is
to like the ultimate one of
responsibility which has him with these
three old people keeping this asteroid
from hitting their village and he has to
do that for the rest of his life and
while the wizard who was a frog with a
bunch of tadpoles in his throat all
speaking in the USA except for one but
they correct that while he's burying one
of the old guys the cruelty to old
people in this show is really quite
staggering he says hey I should use my
magic powers to just move the town out
of the way which is like why couldn't
just use the magic powers to stop the
meteorite but I think this is not the
kind of show to ask questions like that
and even was out of the way and then the
skeleton guy offers a demon hard and
they're like whoa full circle and that's
it I don't have much for this so no I
won't say this um but I am noticing in
the show I think I've talked about this
before like when we talk about humor I
mean that was the old humor very much
based on misery likes
somebody or something has to suffer in
order for comedy to work so really
positive upbeat humor is really hard to
come across you usually need someone
who's either really cynical or sick in
the world or the misfit or the nerd or
whatever and both Finn and Jake
especially Finn are just so upbeat about
everything I mean they are just so
positive and it's so incredibly likeable
and endearing and I love how just
anything that's thrown out they're just
always like yeah let's go let's go yes
yes and just anything that wouldn't
impress anybody they're just like wow
that's amazing and I I really love that
I love how they just enjoy everything
they come across and it's out of so
about this episode especially even
though they got cool whatever magic
powers I don't know was it they had the
magic power at first to control the
little dust yeah my man see dustomancy
and you think that I could be impressed
by a lot so stupid magic power they're
just so this is incredible I mean
they're just so happy to have anything
and that's it's a good attitude I mean
it's good for them I like humor and I
like just characters they're so filled
with that positivity and just fun and
you know do cool stuff like that but I'm
sorry firm that I don't have too much to
say about this episode of what about you
well it's kind of funny because um not
long ago the new Pokemon game came out
and actually this reminds me of kids and
collecting things because they get there
and they have to do these stupid things
to gain stuff that really doesn't help
them in any way shape or form but
they're willing to do whatever it is
possible to complete the set I can see
that but all Finn wants to do is get
that final star so he can have all of
them that's why I think of Pokemon he
wants to collect them all and what do
they do they eat a broom but they have
to spin a coin it's always really simple
and kind of really weird and bizarre
things but they're so excited because oh
my god they're gonna be able to have an
infinite supply of mayonnaise I really
like how I do the one hour joke before I
forget is when the rock comes alive yeah
I'm alive what's going on here
hey that really killed me ah to die no
put that that's a really good point
because uh like even when I was watching
it it's like you know all it's missing
is this one last star well you can't
really get that unless you blah blah
blah and there's a part of me that's
just like uh once you get that star it's
just a big space there and everything
else it fills stars but no it's gotta
have that star that that could just be
OCD though which maybe maybe Pokemon and
all these other marketing ploys are just
playing - everybody's OCD like the ball
gonna have them all um but ya know that
is a good point that it's a lot of these
powers don't even really do much like
whatever it's like the master you can
make this shadow horse but he can't do
anything they can't touch it um yeah
don't be a does use it'll like save the
day I guess fine which also brings up
the whole thing of where he's up there
with the two old people and they're like
no this is the way it's always been done
we have to do it and he's like you know
no youth power forever and he's you know
saying screw the old ways we're gonna do
it the new way which ends up not working
when he's doing it by himself
yeah when the old guys come so it has
it's almost a combination of old and
young have to work together to actually
fix a problem yeah that's true
yeah well especially like just with the
other I mean yeah it's not the ideology
of the old people that saving the day
but them coming with him like here now
it's how do the powers and stuff helps
out very nice man it's sinking way too
deep into this probably but at the same
time it's good you know seeing them get
along and stuff like that open each
other out even though they were
originally using it just to fly away
it's like oh why you up here can help me
why was he burying that one guy that was
so curl I just don't get why they're so
mean to all people in this show it's so
random well the first time it makes
sense though because see they're blowing
up old ladies because that upsets Finn
Finn's trying to protect you know people
especially old ladies but why okay why
is he burying a copy that one I can't
say maybe he's just
guy have you thought of that I really do
love that did I love that one tampon man
because it is like how I like that they
do it early to you know cuz then you're
just constantly questioning like how do
you think no always what to say and they
do it in unison when one could be off by
a second this is like out so that was
pretty funny uh definitely really
creative like I said just just that one
wizard looks like the hypnotoad yeah
it's just getting the throne in the
little temples and it's like whoo I
can't just who would think of that it's
just so strange it out there so yeah I
liked it it is sort of like it sort of
just came and vanished I was just like
what the hell they just see but that's
kind of half the episodes anyway but no
it was fun and I definitely liked it
anything else dead no sleep